Allah puts himself
wherever he pleases
he can go into a manship no it's not
shirt this is what I'm saying to you be
comprehensive if you can't comprehend
him you can't worship that which you
cannot comprehend but can you please
just tell me how do you reconcilable
just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even here what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or the
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the qurani app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
reminders download the Quran app now and
let it testify for you on your mokayama
that you read it wherever you was
I will take the first question yes sir
okay thank you I've listened to you for
about 25 minutes there's a lot of facts
that you speak there's a lot of what a
lot of facts yes sir you speak I
appreciate that
um when it comes to the war between the
west and Russia but that's not really my
concern I'm a Muslim myself I've come to
Islam 10 years ago I just wanted to ask
you a question
yes you can come closer please yeah so
basically in a nutshell I want to know
how you guys the Nation of Islam
do not contribute
class is very clear it is that it says
that Allah is one he is self-sufficient
he does not beget nor is he begotten and
there is nothing like unto him so do you
not realize that you are sharing an
attribute of Allah Allah when it comes
to it is
for that matter where you are claiming
because you praising Allah which is good
I was I was saying the same way
but when it comes to Elijah Muhammad you
guys claim to be a Muslim when you go
into when you have contradicting the
very Foundation of Islam which we come
and preach to the Christians that God is
not a man not a white man or a black man
so can you please just answer my
question you said you don't want to have
that understandable but can you please
just tell me how do you reconcilable all
right I I understand your question and
it's a beautiful question and I thank
you very much for the spirit in which
you answer that question but I will say
this
when we ask a question
we should be intelligent enough to
listen to the answer we should never ask
the question with a preconceived notion
or we believe that we know already in
that oh you're just a bunch of fools so
now you're going to mock them and you're
gonna want to jump in let me say it like
this to you
we agree with Surah in class
say that Allah is one God he's all
independent he begets not nor is he
begotten and there is none comparable
unto him we agree 100
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
he originate
he was not begotten he is self-created
he creates everything
so he's neither begotten nor does he
begin
we agree
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
1400 years ago
went into a cave
and while in that case he heard a voice
read in the name of thy Lord
the prophet said he looked and in all
four corners he saw a man
oh we agree he saw a man that man we
call jibril or the angel Gabriel
the prophet Muhammad one day is Walking
with the companions
a man comes to him
dressed in white the man stops him and
asks him questions about the faith of
Islam
the prophet answers the questions the
man walks away
the prophet turns to the companions do
you know who that was
they said no
he said that's jibril amen
jibril is the one who threw him almighty
God Allah revealed the Holy Quran
makes sense okay the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he never said I am the
prophet of jibril
I am the prophet of Allah
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
was an unlearned man
couldn't read Couldn't Write
look down upon by many there were people
who knew him when he was a child growing
up I think they called it edamin because
he was a beautiful human being but
nonetheless he was not somebody who was
regarded highly in the society in fact
when he married Khadijah it was Khadijah
who basically paid his way
because he had not the resources and
that kind of money so this is not a man
that was you know people are looking up
to him in fact when he said I am the
Messenger of Allah
he was persecuted
I want you to think about some of your
attitudes today
see because they accused the prophet of
blasphemy
because they were worshiping stones and
bricks and snakes and milk in the cover
all manner of idols
but the prophet came and said
as a man
I am the Messenger of Allah but he's a
lonely man
unlearned man can get why to me see
we've got to understand man this is how
Allah works
who is Musa
why is Moses mentioned more in the Holy
Quran than any other people
you just Justified
speaking to him through a burning bush
Moses speaks to Allah
our last speech to Moses Moses is
nervous he's scared he says who shall I
say sent me he says tell him tell
Pharaoh I am that I am in other words I
exist I am real
look man I say it to you like this you
got to listen very carefully to the
language of the Nation of Islam
We Believe now I want you to imagine for
a second
that you are ignorant
that you don't know nothing maybe you're
sitting over there you've got a a tin of
tenants
you're spaced out and and brother Leo
comes to you that's me I'm brotherly I
come to you when I say my brother how
are you you know what's happening man
you say man I'm down I haven't got
nothing whatever and I speak to you for
a few hours about the Beauty and the
majesty and the love of God
and you become inspired from that little
talk and you get up and you go and you
do your shahada and you become a
beautiful Muslim and your life changes
whether you understand this or not
Allah came to you in the person of Leo
Muhammad not that I am Allah
Allah uses human being
Allah don't do magic you don't do Spooks
he comes to men and women through men
and women in the Holy Quran Allah said
had you been an angel I would have sent
you an angel
but because you're a man the prophet
went about in the marketplace eating
food like everybody else
he got sick like everybody else at the
Battle of badal he got wounded like
everybody else
Allah didn't do magic and save him when
they were hunting him the koresh trying
to kill him and he went into that little
cave and the spider made the weapon it
was only that was a law but but not
Magic
the prophet was in danger of dying the
companions had to flee to Ethiopia to
the black people in Africa to for Asylum
when they wanted to kill them Jesus
property this is how Allah works so all
I'm saying to you we understand the
Muslims when they get angry with us
because they believe that we're
practicing shirk I can assure you we're
not doing that we know that Allah is
incomparable but guess what guess what
did you know that there's not another
human being on this planet with your
fingerprint
do you understand it's not another human
being on this planet with the same
dimensions of your retina or anything to
do with you do you know that one side of
your face is completely different to the
other
oh yes sir that means that you are
unique
incomparable but the Muslims we take it
to such an extreme where Allah cannot be
comprehensive if you can't comprehend
him you can't worship that which you
cannot comprehend no you can't look look
believe me it's such a theory
the reason why so many of us are in
trouble today man is because we're
bowing down and we're praying to nothing
we don't believe that Allah has
substance has power look at what this
white man's got
have you seen these weapons
what if I told you
that oh my look how can I explain this
to you
see this
got some electricity in it right
there's no scientist on the planet
that can show you the origin of
electricity
that's why sometimes you can touch
something and you get a little spot
because it's all around it's awesome
it's it's one of the most mysterious
powers in the universe you and I are run
on electricity
brain is electric it's awesome it's
firing right now neurons and neutrons is
phenomenal okay
I've got Electric in me
this has got Electric in it
this is not electricity or the origin or
the source of electricity
Allah puts himself
wherever he pleases
he can go into a man
no it's not shirt this is what I'm
saying to you look look look do you
believe that the Earth is divine no you
don't oh my last says it it's divine oh
yes sir so look it's his creation
everything that Allah everything of
Allah's creation is divine
Leo Muhammad
hold on hold on a second hold on a
second
let me let me just finish the point okay
I don't want to go too far because me
personally I think I've made my point
I I would just say to you
study
see that instruction to the prophet ikra
it wasn't just to the prophet it's all
of us
because many of us today we walk with
the Holy Christ the book says they put
the book behind their backs
and we listen to the shake we listen to
the mullers we listen to the so-called
Scholars
and we are left absolutely messed up I'm
saying Dear Sir dear brother
go and study for yourself and understand
that it is not sure
to understand that Allah is the
influence of men and women
Allah is the power
when I come out here I don't come in
here with no school God my God walks not
just by my side in me around me oh yes
sir oh yes sir
that's the difference
that's what I'm saying so this is where
we have to disagree but but
this is the point this is what we
believe but where's the evidence from
the Quran
no no I understand no no because you
need to be evidently no no I I agree
with you know Allah it wasn't you that
fruit was me that's right I understand
that's right I understand the influence
no no but if you understand that
see the the Christ
the Christ
he causes lame people to walk he causes
dumb people to speak he causes the blind
to see by Allah's permission right no
agree yeah but not Spooks
Allah is moving that man allies in
control of that man thank God he's not
Batman
no Allah is in that man no that no
but that's what I'm saying to you this
is what I'm saying to you electricity is
in here but electricity remains
everywhere but Allah is not electricity
is electronics electricity
look you see this is what I'm saying to
you you know you you want to make Allah
nothing no no that's what you're doing
we're saying that Allah is everything
that's the difference
your Allah is nothing our Allah is
everything yes sir yes sir yes sir
yes sir yes sir we need to speak up
loudly no you're not going to monopolize
the questions go ahead go
this is the reason why guys this is the
reason why the Muslim pen into ship
because he's saying we need substance
we know the problem said anybody that
doesn't see online believe in the
women's agenda the whole point is one we
don't fall into what the Muslim fell
into by thinking we need something that
we can see that is and this brother
without your respect this is the reason
why when it comes to the issue of we're
very careful because I'm not qualified
to say someone you're a cafe but when
somebody comes and says Allah is in me
this is
of Islam and I invite you as well to
Islam yeah this is
God is not a man God is not a man he's
not electric he's not inside us he's not
Elijah Muhammad he's none of these
people so when they come here with the
name of warning he says in the name of
Allah
this is not Islam so we call these
brothers Foundation of Islam back to
back to the true Islam so he is one man
why do you think
we argue with Christians because we're
telling them God is not a white man God
is not a white man is a black man
this is and that's what we ask you
questions like himself and tell them so
it's very funny that when we're trying
to engage with them I asked the simple
questions
I believe that there are obviously
there are many Avenues
miraculous things
by
their group the Nation of Islam executed
come to the true Islam
just before just before you ask the
questions
just understand this though understand
this yeah what these guys you said that
Allah is everything can Allah be that
tree
thank you he created I mean so hold on a
minute hold on a minute Allah is not
against streets Allah doesn't look down
on trees
Allah created the tree in other words he
loves the tree the tree the tree is a
part of his creation but the way you're
talking is if the tree is some separate
and distinct thing that Allah you know
discards he loves his creation Allah
created the horse he created the dog he
loves all of the creatures
except the the rebellious death yes yes
you know what you know why because if he
says yeah then there's a point again
Allah is a man
there you go can you check this out I
would have been a life not a tree but
he's a man what's the difference why not
why
anybody got a question thank you
what's the difference between Christians
one is a white man one is a black God
the question from the gentleman here
with the great top he says who was
Elijah Muhammad
the most honorable Elijah Muhammad We
believe
We Believe
to be the Fulfillment
of the scriptures of the Bible
and the Holy Quran
We Believe
that the most honorable Elijah Muhammad
is that man that the whole world talks
about
but nobody actually believes will make
himself manifest we believe that the
most honorable Elijah Muhammad is the
Christ
the Christ
the son of man written off
we believe that he is the Fulfillment of
that one who almighty God Allah empowers
to crush the wicked
we believe that this man who was
formerly enslaved or a Slave is the
first begotten of those who slept is
that is the language of the Bible we
believe that he is the first begotten of
the Dead We believe that this man was
raised from a spiritually dead condition
which is the condition that most of us
as black people who were enslaved found
ourselves in and we believe that this
man is the man that the world talks
about but it's just talk
and nobody actually expects to see the
manifestation of Christ
Jesus the Christ one who has the power
to crush Wicked people and when Christ
manifests next to him is Matty we
believe that this is
the most honorable Elijah Muhammad and
master foreign
out of us and now one comes to return us
back to our nature so we don't convert
to Islam we revert back to ourselves
thank you where are you now but that's
who we believe the most honorable Elijah
Muhammad we believe him to be the Christ
yes sir
uh so why was he never mentioned by the
prophet Hadith why was he never
mentioned
but how do you know in the Holy Quran no
no he was he was mentioned
in the Holy Quran
he was mentioned taught us the Beauty
and the love of prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him we love him we follow him
we love him we follow him and we follow
the one who came to us because these
Arabs
these pakistanis
he never came to us let's try again they
never came to us
a question we want to answer one
question
and we see this Behavior with the
Christians why because they don't really
have a backbone so I ask simple
questions you claim Elites
yeah yeah okay so basically
yeah I just wanted to speak to him
because at the end of the day this
nation has got nothing to do with Islam
yeah they're not Muslims and I'm very
careful to be doing some fair to people
because this is really very careful
because we have brothers here in the
park who call people Innovative
innovators they're not unqualified
individuals ignoramuses so when it comes
to schooling a a Muslim a cafe is very
dangerous my teachers warned me against
this so I'm very very careful but when
you have somebody who says that Allah
incarnated yet or came as Elijah
Muhammad that is now if you listen
to him very carefully what did he say he
said you you guys worship nothing
meaning that he's saying and this is
exactly what the mushroom fell into
because they are saying we can't see
Allah that's why we need to make our
demigods a small gods so we can touch
and feel them yeah this is the reason
why the Muslims will enter General
inshallah why because we believed in
Allah without seeing our God that is the
whole point so what they're saying is oh
what's the substance oh electric
otherwise electric Allah is in you Allah
is this so you can clearly see he talks
about shaytan but the shaytan is going
through the joke of the vein because
what is the first thing shaytan attacks
you with shirk
the first thing shaytan wants is shrinky
news because when you die in is
hellfire and if you can't do you'll
get into Innovation if your innovation
made yourself so this brother he keeps
talking about shaytan shaitan shaytan
but he himself said he's following in
the footsteps of shaytan we ask Allah to
guide the Nation of Islam back to the
true Islam like Prophet Malcolm X did
because well why they are racist they
are they're committing they're giving
the Asma Allah's names and attributes to
the creation and subhanallah this is far
from Islam he's even saying that Elijah
Muhammad what his name is is the Christ
all against Islams we try to talk we try
to die don't give everyone